i
i do think that we're in a really
terrifying and depressing time
and i think that part of it is we don't
know if something
huge is about to get started and we
don't even know what this is
i mean we just sit here in this weird
world that is falling
into some new state and we're not even
super curious it's like what the hell
just happened
everybody's got an answer and i'm
positive that all of those answers are
wrong
let's let's try to at least sneak up on
the good answer
so the central core of the answer is
that the us
seemed to be the greatest thing in the
world
in large measure because we hadn't
noticed
that we were getting a benefit from
having no plan
not having to make a plan for low growth
as long as we had growth we were in
great shape
let's imagine that there was a that
you could run an experiment you have a
billion copies of earth and you start
the initial conditions slightly
different
on some giant number of planets a lot of
the things
that were discovered from the 1800s
through the end of the 20th century are
discovered in a period of
time because a lot of that just has to
do with once you crack the puzzle of
getting better instruments you can see
more and the more you can see the more
you can make use of what you can see and
it turns out there was lots of stuff to
do
with like you know germs or
electron orbitals or you know spectrum
electromagnetic spectrum so we got to do
all of those things and the us roughly
corresponded for a good
chunk of its history with this bonanza
and so of course we look like an amazing
genius country we have no plan imagine
that you could sell a car you don't have
to put in seat belts you don't have to
put in airbags
you don't have to put in rear view
mirrors or sensors or
a rear view mirror you could save a lot
of money on a car
by not putting in all of the stuff to
keep things from going wrong
and i think that's what we had we had a
machine
that as long as growth was insanely good
we plowed it back
the riches and spoils and then treasure
back into the system and made more
genius stuff and we carried along a good
chunk of humanity hundreds of millions
of people
we did not have a plan for what happens
when the growth goes below
the stall speed of our society
how confident should we be that the
growth has slowed in
in a way that uh is permanent rather
than
a kind of slap in the face where it's
not the right concept
right concept is i i try to use the same
words over and over again in case people
see mold because then
the perseveration actually gets
somewhere so i use this analogy of the
orchard
because everyone talks about low-hanging
fruit they know the concept of
low-hanging fruit
but they don't think in terms of
orchards
so they say things like you think we've
picked all the low-hanging fruit but i
believe in the infinite inventiveness of
the human mind
yeah it's like okay that doesn't even
work as an analogy
what if the idea is we only picked all
the low-hanging fruit here and then
we're having this stupid argument about
low-hanging fruit and we're not going
and looking for new orchards
we're not planting new orchards we're
not looking for forests we're we're just
sitting here arguing about low-hanging
fruit so my claim is there's probably a
lot more low-hanging fruit and it's not
here it's in other orchards it's in
other orchards one of those turned out
to be the digital orchard
the digital orchard has not been as
stagnant
uh as lots of these other like the
chemical
uh orchard you know i
have faith that there is a small
percentage of the population
but not zero that's looking for those
other orchards like i'm excited about
one of those orchards
which is i believe there will be robots
in everybody's homes and that will
unlock some totally new
thing totally new set of technologies
ideas
the way we live life the productivity
all
the everything it'll change everything
so i'm excited about that orchard
some you know i'm roaming that orchard
and
wondering how the hell you kind of bring
back like the ant that finds a new
source of food yeah i'm trying to find
an apple i can bring back to the
the great so you're in an you're in in
an
explorer idiom and you have faith that
there's enough
of those i don't think there are very
many of us i mean i'm one of them too
yeah
how many does it take it takes one
it end one end what are you talking
about
how many uh elons does it take to screw
in a light bulb
okay let's imagine that we went
imagine some ant goes and finds a new
source of food
yeah right and then it comes back to the
colony
and it says hey i think i found a new
source of food and the
initial reaction is you're not you're
not authorized to find new food
what why would you try to go find new
food we're going to remove you from
twitter
yeah and by the way i think the fact
that you think you're allowed to go find
you
shows how privileged you are as an aunt
get out of the colony kill him kill him
well that's probably not a great model
for finding new orchards
and i think that what we find is that
where there's a system that allows
somebody to ascend without a lot of
gatekeeping
you can have that but you know i saw
this happen in hedge funds hedge funds
for a while
uh hoovered up a lot of talent because
they were places that had funding and
had freedom
and in general really smart people
want to be free and they don't want to
think a lot about
how they're going to you know feed
themselves they want to get lost in
their minds
so you can either give them productive
places to play dangerous places to play
you know they're either going to break
into computers or find vaccines for you
or build bombs
or build companies and we're not
providing
for the people who have to disrupt and
have to innovate
and trying to channel that effort we're
so focused on this other
thing which is like fairness and safety
and fairness and safety by the way are
really important i don't want to
denigrate them
but the singular focus on fairness and
safety without
in the same breath being focused on
growth and discovery and creation
is going to doom us because what we're
talking about is we're always talking
about divvying up the pie that is
as opposed to the pie that will be
imagine that you spent all your time
trying to divvy up the 13th century pie
and you destroyed your ability to get to
the 20th century
you'd be an idiot but one place i think
i disagree with you
is uh i don't think you need that many
people to empower
the geniuses the innovators the people
who refuse to
spend most of their days in meetings
about fairness this is good
let's have a disagreement i think
podcasting whatever you call that medium
is just one little example of a tool
that you can give
power to like you and your podcast can
have
the next elon musk and make them a star
now i see where you're going
okay there has been a series of places
for people to play
and be free and we've lost them
successively
what's a good place you remember because
i disagree with you there too
i think they're still there you can
still play you interviewed
noam chomsky yes okay
noam chomsky comes from an era well you
can play
where you could play at mit at mit
and you can't play this is where i
disagree with you we've already had this
but go check the clips channel for the
lexi friedman podcast
i i think i wasn't brave enough at that
time and i'm not really brave enough
now come on because that's the vodka uh
it's a feeling and people are gonna tear
me apart oh what do you and and
you speak from emotions and facts
the feeling the podcast is this it's
yours yes okay
tell the people who are currently
editing your brain because i saw that
move right now yeah
they should go find another podcast
right let's get rid of some of your
audience
right now yeah please go find another
podcast if you're editing my brain
nevertheless
all the self-doubt they're sitting in
that brain so i can't stand to watch
this but all right
okay what is the self-doubt loop that
you're in the thing is
when i walk the halls of mit
yeah there's bureaucracy there's
administrators that never have done
anything interesting in their entire
lives
there's meetings there's all these crap
all the usual crap
but there's in the eyes of individuals
yeah there's this glow of excitement has
nothing to do with career
i understand this and this is it's still
a playground there's little
little pockets of playgrounds from which
genius can
emerge still and they're unaffected by
diversity meetings or fairness meetings
or
or blah blah blah i love to hear this
yeah but you don't think so i don't
believe it
because i've watched the change lex i've
watched people and we're all editing
ourselves all the time
i remember my old mind i liked it better
all of this relentless focus on critical
race theory and
you know critical theory post-modernism
fairness
social justice it's making many of us
into worse
people you think that's that do you
think the mad demons are
of you know the character is paying
attention to any of that
you think that has an effect have you
seen what happened to matt damon himself
matt damon has tried to say various
things at various times that seem to be
relatively innocuous
he can't can't speak okay well let's
let's not
mix up matt damon is just an actor well
i don't know
he was just a harvard student who came
up with his own genius screen play acted
and made it happen
no yeah no but where somewhere else you
don't think you can build the rocket
company
so i think that there are things that
you can still do
but we're losing them we lose them we
keep losing them
i would say the biggest problem here let
me just say like what i think the
solution would be
is to fire anybody who is
doesn't like who's not fact like faculty
especially young faculty should have way
more power and administration should
have much less power
because right now the administration
which used some of the who used to be
faculty but they've lost
the fire the spark that gave them
they've lost the memories of the
playground
and so the people that admire and love
the playground like you could see it in
their behavior should have way more
power
and so we should create a systems that
give them power
you're very idealistic yeah and you're
very you've got a huge heart
it's a weird time because i don't want
to dissuade you
from believing beautiful things
because i see how potent you are you you
do all these things jiu jitsu guitar
podcasting
programming computers
etc etc i don't think you're right i
think we're in a really
deeply screwed up place
you